one thing that I find myself mentioning
an awful lot in these video blogs is
Doctor Who Doctor Who Doctor Who Doctor
Who Doctor Who Doctor Who but what is it
what the hell am I talking about well
doctor who is a British TV show about a
nine hundred year old alien who travels
through time and space in a blue box
which if you're someone who's never
experienced Doctor Who probably sounds
like the weirdest idea for a TV show
that you've ever heard but it's a bit of
a national treasure for us Brits
probably because of its longevity I mean
it's been on TV since 1963 in fact my
mum actually saw the first-ever episode
when it was being broadcast when he saw
the first-ever episode of Doctor Who how
old were you I was very very young I'd
rather not give my age away okay did you
use to hide behind the sofa when you
watching it it does sound like a bit of
a cliche but my brothers and I
definitely did hide behind a safe when
we were watching a Daleks just for
people who don't know what a Dalek is my
mum has one here it's basically a Doctor
Who enemy bad guy person so there's been
no escaping Doctor Who in my life him
knowing your life time charlie now one
of the loveliest things about old doctor
who was that the special effects were
adorable which is basically a nice way
of saying that they were terrible in
fact nowadays I could do better special
effects just sitting here on my bedroom
one of the reasons that doctor who's
been on TV for so long is that the
character the doctor the nine hundred
year old alien he has this way of
cheating depth whenever he dies he
regenerates every single atom in his
body starts afresh he gets in your body
he gets a new personality and he keeps
on living which in terms of the real
world means that some other actor comes
in it starts playing now I usually cite
Doctor Who as being my favorite TV show
which to a casual viewer of the show
might seem a little bit of an odd thing
to say
I mean sometimes the show could be
brilliant you know great stories scary
monsters witty dialogue when it's good
it's the best but when it's bad it's
really really really really bad for
example there's this one episode called
the unicorn and the wasp in which a
giant wasp kills a man with lead piping
and then the giant wasp goes and falls
in love with a human it's it's absurd I
mean that's just my opinion but it's
it's really pretty rich so given that
it's pretty hit and miss I mean why is
it so popular why is it my favorite TV
show well not only does it have this
massive legacy attached to it but I
think and this is just me speculating I
think that people love the
episodes as much as they love the good
episodes there's a great community
attached to Doctor Who cool
whoo viens and I guess I would consider
myself a Whovian and I see who viens is
one of the TV critics you know people
who love to pick apart the plot holes
and point out the bad dialogue and and
cringe at the really bad CGI but also
when they can revel in the brilliant
acting in the amazing plot twists I
guess I'm making this video to try and
justify to you and to myself I guess why
I consider Doctor Who to be my favorite
TV show I know for a fact that my
brother and sister think I'm a bit odd
in liking Doctor Who as much as I do
especially my brother who thinks it's
awful which it is at times you know I
look bit mad but I think that's one of
the great things about it that's this is
just the opinion of one person if you
like doctor do tell me why and if you
don't like Doctor Who tell me why as
well I'm interested and if you're
someone that's never seen Doctor Who
then I would definitely recommend it
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool given the
doctor who's a science fiction show I
wore my science t-shirt today
exterminate exterminate that's a really
bad impersonation sorry